we enjoying our hearts we have joy in
our hearts because there are still video
games coming out in 2015 look I know
we've talked a lot about all the games
of coming out in 2016 lots of slippage
lots of games that we were previously
looking forward to that are maybe not
coming out but let's not worry about us
there's still some great games coming
out in 2015 first one up witcher 3 wild
hunt yeah dude you came back from poland
super hyped on that game pretty much
everywhere talk too hyped on that game
of hide down that game yes I super mean
anyone played some it was good fun Kevin
you played some gigs goes well yeah
before that I played some yeah yeah we
had joined the lobby talking about it
are you still looking forward to the
witches oh yeah yeah I'm trying I'm
trying to be you know you know trying to
keep things calm and cool and collected
and distant knock you know I gotta gotta
be a little objective about these things
but totally I'm looking forward to that
was my most anticipated game of the year
so it's hard not to be excited about it
cuz i love the witcher 2 so much but
what I really wanted was for that game
to be I wanted it to be bigger um and my
other issue with it is it just comes to
a crap ending all right now I really
wanted like I really wanted something
just a little bit bigger and adventurous
and a little let a little less enclosed
and it looks like this is exactly what
I've always wanted it to be I mean I
think the CD Projekt RED sort of proves
that you don't have to choose one thing
over another anymore in RPGs everybody's
always like oh well it's a big game you
have to have this and you have to give
up this will know you can have a cool
world and pretty graphics and a cool
main character and good combat and great
systems and blah blah blah like you can
have all of those things in one game I
think the witcher 2 got kind of close to
that yeah and it seems like it with this
sort of from when we were talking to
those guys in warsaw you can tell that
the expansion of their team has
definitely helped them sort of up the
ante in terms of the scope of this game
from playing with andy it felt more like
playing a fantasy red dead redemption
than it did playing like a sequel to a
linear role-playing game only I mean it
looks like the kind of thing where say
if if if EA were making this for example
and they told us it was like oh it's a
600 member
development team yeah you totally
believe that yeah absolutely and when
you think about some of the open world
games came here last year and games that
like like you know watch dogs and
Assassin's which people some people
enjoy but our people thought fell short
and then you think about how this game
looks at least on paper and I'm I'm very
excited this thing I haven't seen this
yeah fight riff credible it's dope I
played of Griffin bowel that went into
like the griffon straight up just flew
up and went somewhere else like to
follow him on my arse yeah yeah get back
there by the way this is a wyvern oh is
it just well sorry it's not to Griffin
my god let's let's whyever together and
we'll have a bunch of features on
gamespot starting and monday after next
with a bunch of new information on this
they've already nested they're gonna
have two more expansion packs which are
going to open unlock sort of to new
areas in the game that's something I'm
looking forward to talking about in
those videos the open-world nature of
this game it's not so much one big world
as it is a bunch of other like there's
one large open world section and then
other sort of places you can travel to
which are open worlds in up themselves
yeah but you're gonna have to wait a
little while like Hyrule kinda yeah man
but that one big main one pretty big
pretty dang let's keep talking talking
about some other games and I've never
been a massive fan of the Arkham series
but fans of letters are very excited to
play arkham knight which is coming out a
couple of months time I've ever study
for that rock steady joint yeah I mean
that this is what I mean I personally
think that delays are always good
because one hundred percent of the time
it's going to be for the benefit of the
game um so I'm not somebody who gets
upset at all over delays and I feel
especially for a game like the Arkham
games I think they live and die on the
amount of I hate the word look I'm gonna
say the word polish just the amount like
remember when r comes the year Arkham
City came out portal 2 also came out oh
wow and I feel like those two games are
the epitome of what we think about as
polish in video games and I feel like
without it you know an arkham game would
lose something and so I'm just I'm
really excited about the delay because
that just tells me they're taking the
level of refinement in the game super
seriously because if there's their their
games that are as close to mechanically
perfect and have
good game feel it would be the Arkham
games I don't know I just I think
they're great I didn't play the recent
one which was a different developer at
current slated currently slated for june
twenty third it's the second game on the
list that has been delayed of course
would you three suppose commit last year
as well currently slated for May
nineteenth so both those games we're
gonna have in the next couple of months
I one of them before e3 other games are
coming at this year at Just Cause 3 I've
lashawn have a date for this one yet and
so fingers crossed it'll be some stages
yet look at this what's going on here yo
nothing on [ __ ] good I'm fine it
looks like you are having a fellow I was
thinking of something so it's just cuz
three uh tell me this is this going to
include the multiplayer that has like
showed up on these 100 vs hundreds or
yeah or some some part of it because
that was like an entirely unofficial
part of just cause they then made
official again or official they brought
it into the fold yo it's presumably just
cos 3 will hobbs i don't know i think i
remember them saying something like they
were going to bring that into the fold
for three they don't date for this yet
announcer avalanche are working on that
mad max game which is currently slated
for September first so this may be one
of the we may see in twenty sixteen
games who knows his max you know just
goes because we just happen oh yeah just
cars can slide Mad Max is tied to a
movie release date yeah it's probably
going they caught her economy oh yeah
that's true men and Mad Max comes out
the same day yes as something human or
solid Oh water that's gonna be a ride
bangers and that's going to come as
because it seems like Kaname might be
paying its series creator past December
31st rumors are to be believed metal
gear solid 5 I absolutely adored
grandiose you guys looking forward to
the phantom pain yeah totally no I mean
I'll you know we have great
conversations in the office about which
metal gear is better than other metal
gears and so on like ranking them and
everybody knows how much I love metal
gear solid four um it was the only ten I
yes given her um and I think that game
was just the bee's knees is that a thing
the kids say sure all his kids is in
here so
so I'm super looking forward to it
what's funny though is that I still
haven't finished ground zeroes believe
it or not okay I finished the first
mission yeah and I keep thinking I'm
gonna sit down and get ground zeroes and
I'm like I'm not in the mood for
something this heavy I think I'd rather
do something a little bit easier
heartedly blood-borne or Orion the Black
Forest and metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain if you're interested in
this a tweet out fiddle club with a
hashtag beez kneez little bit fiddly
co-op sorry I feel clean don't send me a
hashtag bee's knees please do please
send him pictures of actual bee's knees
hashtag bees knees at me it's kind of
interesting too great linear
first-person action games Witcher and
Milly Quezada is going open world this
year at Chris your big halo 5 halo 5
Guardians oh yeah they've started their
cryptic trailer campaign ya goin down
reminding you all to watch halo
nightfall live action seriously that's
little 5 Guardians I don't know man like
I've enjoyed some halo stories I thought
halo 4 was pretty much the BET the best
storytelling a halo game has ever had
norib mainline hallo master chief halo
game ODST is a different discussion yeah
but Luke's beer yeah non-canonical no I
mean I'm always I'm always interested to
see what new halo comes out because they
sort of have that halo feel to them
which feels really good to me you know
in terms of the pace I was interested
because the multiplayer beta this year
like they're definitely overhauling a
lot about sort of the pace and some of
the mechanics of this sort of these
physical physically of the the sort of
body on body moves which I'm really
interested in because halo to me
multiplayer at least has always had more
actual combat than any other
first-person shooter moments like the
moment where you are actually in combat
fighting someone moving around them last
way longer than in call of duty than in
anything you know and then in most of
them in battle field etc etc glorified
duck hunts they feel like sometimes yeah
I did so it's over so quickly once
someone gets a few bullets on someone
because of this halo systems yeah I I'll
be able to see what they do with the
story certainly they have big narrative
ambitions with all the stuff they've
been doing out of 3 for 3 with the TV
series and two stars every story and
yell and all these this story stuff with
the trailer so uh I'm looking forward to
it but it's not a game that I I don't
know those trailers didn't get me you
know hyped for well don't worry cuz it's
at an october twenty seventh which means
we've got about five months left of
weirds trailers to watch between yeah no
problem now so we got a few few more
trade shows they gotta show up big ad
yeah good point and so that's sort of it
for the games that we have dates for but
there's a bunch of other games that are
supposedly coming out this year
assassin's creed victory okay that'll be
an assassin's creed game this year yeah
their plans are gonna be a call of duty
case here too they released like three
assassins creed games last year right so
why not they've already released one
this year yeah the suit yeah all right
wait what did they make that china
chronicles whatever like a 2d platformer
think the one that looks like shank it's
out or close to being out yeah we had a
trailer for it on the show reasoning
I'll get victory yeah set in Victorian
London it's really helpful that it's
like right there in the title yeah
thanks very much because it's bit it's
getting harder let's be honest to pick
out which ones which historical setting
speaking of annualized franchises I'm
guessing we'll hear about like Call of
Duty at some stage like in the next like
e3's on pretty soon socially Barbara Ann
yeah advanced warfare gotten their DLC
pushes out it's time to time to start
revving it up for the next even more
advanced warfare perhaps advanced
advanced or word monster warfare the
blackest ops and what else we got star
wars battlefront oh yeah oh yeah guys
you sure that's Kevin I'm excited i
really i really like star wars
battlefront so I'm really excited about
star wars battlefront free you know I
all right you are you just excited to
like fly a friggin plane around the legs
of an 80 80 again is that you just want
to shoot some people in the icy
wasteland of Hoth what do you want from
battlefront oh yeah those are awful
things I would hate a face nothing it
sounds like eight games yeah but now
it's gonna be an HD or some [ __ ] I'm
gonna fortune it's fun don't get your
level shut up I want a good fun
battlefield game and guess what that's
what they need to do is go that's what
it's gonna be yeah I do Vietnam style
just start putting punji sticks and
Huey's a play music crap like yet the
tangible levels
perfectly just have fun with it just to
go have fun with it again do you
remember the Star Wars RTS that was
basically just age of empires with Star
Wars stuff in the innocence of our eyes
yeah that was that was I mean I was ages
ago but I just just do that with
battlefield that's fine and they do know
the place all the things with suburban
tailings we're fine yeah I'm a little
bigger nice tell you I'm not actually
saying I think that would be Star Wars
been pretty good for game releases those
Jedi Knight games were pretty fantastic
at moving on I don't think we're gonna
see either these games this year the
division oh yeah mm-hmm well I think I
haven't heard a lot about it now there's
a pretty mom which is not you be style
no so-so chances of a delay are pretty
good that we feel like we'd be on the
the workup now in the marketing's like
yeah division if it we're still coming
up also if they've got rainbow six siege
coming later this year and Assassin's
Creed it seems like I feel like they
have got to have learned some kind of
lesson from watchdogs and the cycle of
such hype to that game to such deflation
yeah warp on its actual release that
yeah the division i feel like is yeah
probably won't see it this year I think
watch dogs to write like that that's
just a rumor kind of thing but yeah
definitive rumor as far as we know who
knows mencia d3 i'm very much looking
forward to division it looks you know if
they deliver on what they're promising i
think that can be kind of cool and feels
like one of those games like you know
what take your time with it if it's you
know i rather play let's not have a
watchdog situation where it kind of
feels like it was maybe pushed out the
gate a little bit too early yeah and
let's not have like the thing that I'm
hoping that they do with the division
and the Tom Clancy games have done a
pretty good job of getting away from
this anyway I just don't want to see
that Ubisoft formula layered on top of
the day all over again which is just
like here all of the places with all of
the content yeah and you go out there
and you climb a tower to unlock more
content it kind of works with song is I
think far cry 4 it kind of works with ya
playful I love that game it's the reason
that they do it is because it's
effective but after a while like when
the crew and far cry and Assassin's
Creed all kind of follow that same
formula I'm ready for something
different and typically you know
splinter cell doesn't do that so
hopefully the division 1 yeah they go
baby the child death confirmed there as
well
much rough trailer talk about which
keeps coming up in like lists of games
coming out in 2015 but I'm not so sure
and no man's sky you guys think we're
gonna see it out on ps4 and PC in the
2015 year of our Lord no Lord Gabe I
don't know man they've been at it for a
while haven't they I have no concept of
this you did the whole friggin deep dive
feature with them Dukes really like you
should have the you should give us a
little give us a little more on why you
think that it's not coming out this year
cuz they get the scope of their ambition
I feel like the scope the initial scope
of their ambition seems to have been
already demonstrated today in terms of
the size of this world that they're
gonna let people be in but then the
question was what's what is it what does
an hour of gameplay like what is the
motivations I don't know yeah it was
that the question it kind of feels like
they've there the grand concept of what
this game is is very finalized and it
seems like from the tools that we saw
them use that like dash in terms of like
does it work does work but I think
that's exactly what you're talking about
if they could see what is the flow of
the game have very much felt like back
ash the PlayStation experience and
certainly back at e3 like that still
hadn't been nailed down yeah and so and
that stuff is like expensive in terms of
time like content is super time
expensive like that and or not content
cuz the contents kind of done with this
procedural system they have but like
that sizes like systems yet retaining
that stuff at the tasting it yeah
especially in a dynamic world like this
sure yet to do exactly yeah i mean but
already I mean the thing is elite
dangerous has been remarkably successful
and honestly it kind of I feel like that
falls more or less in the same category
which is like it's a you know you've got
all these places to go but the do the
things that you do don't actually change
all that much and ultimately I think for
a lot of people that can that can lead
to stagnation I think if they just I
don't think they need to like throw in
too many systems to make this game
interesting but I would like them to see
I'll see them deliver more on the do in
ways that elite dangerous does not yes
like I agree that's it's pretty limited
not in that respect at least now they're
going to keep out into I mean this looks
like cooler stuff than I typically did
in the lead a yes so I have you know if
that's what this if that's what they do
is
make space battles really cool then
grind with me forget that show me more
mining more docking procedures I just
want to get up on a damn dinosaur can I
walk up its tail and like get on like I
don't know like find out later this year
I know parkour najin and so that's kind
of all the big old games that are coming
out in 2015 if you think we missed any
off that list by all means put them in
the comments below and finally we've got
some games coming out next week grand
theft auto 5 or the combat oh yeah more
common X on that pc dear dmx grant x
which is dmx green screen big production
crew oh yeah I coming back at the hammer
time and that's the lobby for this week
Kevin Von word Chris waters thanks so
much higher
you